strong minds discuss ideas
average minds discuss events
weak minds discuss people
be kind
for everyone you meet is fighting a hard
battle
he who was not contented with what he
has
would not be contented with what he
would like to have
the only true wisdom is in knowing you
know nothing
the more i know
the more i realize i know nothing
the unexamined life
is not worth living
by all means marry
if you get a good wife
you'll become happy
if you get a bad one
you'll become a philosopher
let him who would move the world
first move himself
death may be the greatest of all human
blessings
the only good is knowledge
and the only evil
is ignorance
preferred knowledge to wealth
for the one is transitory
the other perpetual
mankind is made of two kinds of people
wise people who know they're fools
and fools
who think they are wise
fear of women
love more than hate the man
understanding a question
is half an answer
thou should just eat to live
not live to eat
those who are hardest to love need it
the most
i know you won't believe me
but the highest form of human excellence
is to question oneself and others
be as you wish to seem
we cannot live better than in seeking to
become better
i would rather die having spoken after
my manner
and speak in your manner and live
smart people learn from everything and
everyone
average people from their experiences
stupid people already have all the
answers
in childhood be modest
and youth temperate
in adulthood just
and in old age prudent
remember that there is nothing stable in
human affairs
therefore avoid undue elation and
prosperity
or undo depression in adversity
it is better to suffer wrong
than to do wrong
no man is capable of causing great evil
without thinking he's doing the right
thing
our next video will definitely surprise
you
click on it